AT THE OTHER END OF THE ICE
ILIA SOROKIN  T THE BATTLE AGAI
THREE ISLANDERS.
BROCK NELSON COMES AWAY WITH
IT.
ROY
26 SAVES.  LENNAR ON THE INITIA
SHOT AND IT GOES RIGHT TO
BAILEY.
44-YEAR-OLD
VETERAN BACK WHERE IT ALL BEGAN
PLAY THE THERE . HE WILLLLTHE
BOARDS.
STEPHENSON ON THE WINGS.
BACK TO ING.
PLUS HE PLAYED BEFORE ME WITH Y
IN OTTAWA FOR THREE YEARS AND
NELSON AND
THE ISLANDERS ON THE COUNTER
R WAY.
AND BROCK NELSON A BIG
ADVANTAGE BY SOROKIN.
MAKNIGHTS . THE
ISLANDERS WENT OVER SEVEN
MINUTELAST YEAR BEFORE
DRIVING DEEP GETTING TO THE
POINT.
BOARD SHOTS HAVE TO
THEODORE TURNED OVER AND THAT
CREATES CHANCES AS THE PICKS
UP PRETTY WELL GOING INTO THE
NEW BUILDING AND TING THROUGH T
CREASE.
NELSON,  FEED THROUGH THE CREAS
GOAL YEAR BEFORE
THE COG LYNN.
ZACH PARISE, ANOTHER
SOROKA AND HAD A SHUT OUT LAST
NIGHT AND HE IS 25-25 TONIGHT.
>> R
BAILEY.
AND HERE IS WAHLSTROM.
HE WILL WIND T ALL OF THAT.
IT COMES OFF KARLSSON'S  STICK.
EVERYONE IS
BEAUVILLIER AND LEE, BAILEY
GAINS A LINE TO PARIS  ALL ALON
LEHNER WITH A STOP . NOW NELSON
INTO OVER THE LEFT
SHOULDER.
KREBS COMING BACK TAKES AWAY D
AN EXTRA ATTACKER MARCHESSAULT
PUCK W